if you've ever been to a game from
basically 2014 to the last game we
played you have witnessed firsthand his
energy his passion his emotion that he
has for the Clippers
please welcome Clippers Chairman Steve
Ballmer
love you dare I have these notes like I
say I'm just fired up to be here today
I'm just delighted you know I'm proud of
what we did last year we had a hell of a
team played the right way hard ready
taut resilient that's what the Clippers
are about and I just moves great season
great season 48 wins great season not
one but a very great season I'm so proud
of the guys we have I'm so proud of the
guys who are coming back we got the guys
who I think will be perfect to put
together with Paul and Kai's to really
give us the chance to do the only real
thing we want to do I gotta say being
number two being number four we're only
here for one reason we want to win at
all there's only one reason I'm proud of
our leadership team to put us in this
position where we could put together two
of the guys who I have most admired
throughout their careers I'm excited
about that and proud of the guys who who
got us here I'm proud to be here in this
rec center I know kids we got you out of
your routine today but I'm proud to be
here with you it's real honored to have
a chance to be here and have us be so
welcome in this place matters a lot to
the Clippers what our world is like off
the court and the contributions we get
to make and the contributions our
players get to make but most of all I'm
pumped say hello it's Clippers to Paul
and Kauai
[Applause]
yeah
that's why we're here - then we got two
guys who I am so excited to have two
guys who are tough you watch and play
they're tough I love the toughness two
guys who every year every year have
gotten better every year
that's the kind of that's look I'm
inspired by that work offseason
off-court work work work work work two
guys two guys who are MVP guys Paul was
having the most impressive season the
year no a little injury third in the MVP
voting third a guy who could be first
third who I am BP of the NBA Finals man
that's pretty damn good
you don't think when you win some
bondage this year with ballin quiet
Artie will win some ball games but
there's only a few games we need to need
we need to win the last game played
during the NBA season that's the game we
got to win qui said something when they
won the championship this year about the
Larry Obi the only thing that mattered
since the Larry Obi
when I first got here I think I called
it the Lawrence O'Brien but from now on
it's all about the Larry Obi so are you
a chance to hear from quiet pull here in
a minute
we did a little video we'd like to show
you first Thanks
[Applause]